G fuel (xD)
G fuel is running a big contest (woah)
glug-glug-glug (help)
Ten grand lucky son of a gun winners will win the opportunity of a lifetime if I may say so myself (yes dad)
One year supply of G fuel. Say it with me one year supply of G fuel (omg yis)
Just imagine what you can do with that (murder people)
That's 12 tubs of G fuel baby one
PewDiePie G fuel starter kit my god, if you haven't signed up for this yet boy (hes gonna spank ya)
I got bad news for you. You're a dummy ball (glug-glug-glug-glug x4)
One collector's edition G fuel pin. Okay. Alright
(very niceee)
My god a G fuel collectors pin guys. How do you understand? Do you understand?
And this is not just it the twenty runner-up will receive a G fuel starter kit!!
Or and a collector's G fuel pink. Listen up guys link
It's in the description. You know what to do miss freaking get this bread. That's right everyone. I just throw it out there
It's such a good person. I know (we know)
It's Photoshop time, babyyyyy
yyyyyyyyyy
yeyyy
So many people have been literally begging me to do another Photoshop video and I always say no that's a terrible idea
But hey here, we are everyone Photoshop
HeY fEliX cAn YoU PhOtOsHoP soMeThNIg pleAsE
*claps hands* (meme 👏 rev- wait..)
FINE there has been a couple things
that have been bothering me that I haven't seen anyone do properly
So I guess I will have to do this number one Will Smith genie looks like trash
How can we make it better? Everyone hates this genie?
You know, I'm not supposed to give my opinion, but I think it's kind of hot. This really looks like a bad
Just face slapped on
*creepy laugh* hEHheHheH
like- (like waht??/?)
It just looks terrible you can literally add any face on top of this so easily
I Think- I think what
Gives it away. It's honestly this line here
I don't know if this is intentional but this it's almost like you can
It's something like you can see like where they cut his face onto this 3d model or however they did it (ow)
I don't know or maybe that's just like a small mistake. Is it in the other shots?
Guess this is the shape of his face, but I think I'm just curious
*more creepy laughs* heHehEh
*Whistles* whwee  ee wwhhyooo oo
oo
*cREeePy laUgh* HehHhHEheh
10 out of 10, baby, haha
*4th time now* EHhehehEHh
aaHhH That's great
*queit crreeepyy lauughh* HehEhH
Kind of perfectly
Decrease the noise fix the light thing. There we go
Starting to look decent fix his lip really quick. I don't know why I did this. It's not funny. There's nothing to it
I just wanted to see if I could do it better (u did)
Which I clearly can't cuz the forhead is all fucked (no u did!!1!1one)
There you go everyone new and improved now for the final detail (yeeeeey)
(hawt)
There we go
now that's an Alladin that I would personally watch
and it's family-friendly (indeed)
Thanks to me. You're welcome Disney.
I'll be waiting for my paycheck.
What would be the worst face to have on this body
*creepy laughter again- creepy how much he laughs like this*  HehEHheh
*more* HeHeEHehh
*annnnd moreee*  hAhaEHhaeh
she make me laugh
HhaHAh my Tod (my god^)
EhaHEHaheh
*wHEEZe*
AhhEHEHhe
*whEHeEeeZE
Ohh God
CkA
*high pitched crrepy laugh* AhAhahahaheh
HHeHEHAhEh
Marzia,
Im SorrEeeyYY
Okay. I just wha- sometimes I get questions that I know I don't want the answer for but I need to see it
I need to witness it. Okay. This is a straight-up nightmare fuel
MWAH
It's a masterpiece
Honestly, it doesn't even look bad
AHHAEhahEHh
Oh I just realized
The bit- the bit-  (spit iT oUT feLiX)
Here's the lips and then the beard is down here
But we cannot have that. Okay. I actually like it Marzia I confirmed for the next Disney film
*HuhHhHHhh???/???/?//*
Looks like they fired Will Smith and went with what?
*pause as felix realizes he cant spell*
They- OhHh
And went with what should have been their first option for the genie
There we go. Like everyone going who is that? Who who's that Felix?
*creepy laugh #12 as i've counted* Hahheh Eh AHha
*cOuGh haCk wHeEze*
A lot of people have been talking about how Will Smith looks like
Blue shrek, so I'm curious. How exactly
Does blue Shrek actually look like, you know every single day
I just sit here and I use the pen tool to crop myself out
*no pity detected*
You know, I'd like to think at least, you know, I'm getting better at Photoshop for doing these god-awful thumbnails every day
When in reality
*Breaths heavily on mic*
I'm just a god at using the pen tool
*#13(?)* HWhehah
It's all it's ever done for me first of all we need to put
Him in the right location to really immerse ourself into the landscape
Juzzan (shazam?) that looks terrible
Hey, you know I can work with it these are better but
Yeah, okay. Here we go. Okay, I like this one. I think this is the keeper
Now, of course, we're gonna have to turn them green
Which is probably one of the most difficult things you could ever possibly do. All right, we're done
DeHEhahEhHEhah
WhEzEe HEHhehah
What is the color strength tho like is he that's a disgusting yellow, isn't it
now of course the most iconic part of Shrek- the ears everyone
AhEHEH
It actually works. That's the weakest part
AHehhahehe
Did you guys know that Will Smith was actually gonna play Shrek, but he said no
(o really??)
Because he was gonna play in Wild West instead
(wow, CRaZyy, i never knew)
Crazy, I know
(i know thats wat i said.)
Legit legit like I don't think that needs more work
AheHAHhehe
I mean, I guess I guess I should cover up this but still
ThATsss itt
ThatSs iT
Ohh Yea ;)
OhHH YAHHhHH
OhH YeAhaHHh sonNN (yes dad)
Look at that look at that ears. Look at those. I want to suck on that
(me too)
Alright you can judge me all you want everyone has wanted to suck on Shreks ears god dammit I just realized
His left one is bigger than the right one that's just ridiculous. We cannot have that that's more like it
I guess I guess we have to get rid of his
hats thing hair
His Hair felix. Oh, okay. Sorry should be simple. Delete
And I will fill in -will fill in the blank word alone. I mean, it doesn't look bad. There you go
There yaA goOoo
Fixed your thing. Why am I wasting time doing this?
Why just suffer I just want to see it through, you know
HeheHHhe
I just want to see it through I told you guys
When I get an idea
Even if it's not good, I want to see ITTTTT
(omg yes dad so hawt)
Aheahehehhahh
EhhHhH god
alright im doing it all wrong so
(MEME 👏 REVI- aww)
(Mentally thinks: what am i doing with my life. i wasted so much time i should be with Marzia rite now or with edgar. how did this happen where did i go wrong. i thot i had a future but nooo. i should have never touched photoshop in the first place. i guess this is it guys. welp.no, NO, pull it together felix u can do it!!1!1!!)
You guys think this is Shrek the vest
I don't but it's a clothes that I can find, okay
eHHEheHE hEHEHEH
Why am I laughing it's not even funny. Okay. Oh, yeah, you'd only coverage like part of his body. Hey look we added a texture
Look at that bois
BAM
It looks just like the real
ahHEHAahEh
ohh
WhY aM i DoInG THIS??!?1?1?!??!/1!/
STAaaAP
Well here goes it's Shrek here. That's not the Shrek voice you idiot.
*bad shrek immitation* Hey guys it me shrek
What's a Shrek? What's the Shrek boys? An OGrE. I'm a ogr-
Okay, I don't do impressions I do Photoshop, please okay, is there any good reason to do this
(yes. us. u do it for us)
No (oh.)
is there any good reason to do anything in life ?
NO, so there you have it kids
toE (oh) my godd
(im not gonna say meme👏 review 👏again....oops)
EHHHH Ha hAhAH
WHeeZE
AHHahaeheaH
*enhales deeply*
ehhhh garglegarglegarglegarglegargle
Another
Masterpiece thank you very much. I think it's time we let this one go though
Actually, let me see before and after because I'm curious what I've done before.
AheHAHeaeh
see they both look shit Oh God, they both look like honestly, they both look so bad Oh,
AhHEhEAHEAH
they both so bad
AhAH
OhhH
God
Disney needs to hire me. Come on
I mean don't they're just gonna fire me. But anyway mission accomplished
(we thin so. do u, FeliX?
I think so (gud)
Okay, as you may or may not know dog Bowser is the new CEO Nintendo America Dog Bowser
New CEO of Nintendo America, very, you know with a name like that
Yeah, clearly people want to see the transformation right of Bowser turning into actual Bowser
It's not like he's probably heard this joke a million times before. I mean, look at people done- people done this and it's like nOOo
We want a proper one. I mean that I'll hand it to the bowset ones are pretty good
But I want an actual bowser, because he's not Bowset god damn it
Oh, yes ohh the quality
The QuaLiTtYY
Never leave high quality photos on the internet. Just don't do it
It ain't worth it. Oh my god. Yes dog
First of all if your listen watching and listening, I'm sorry. Okay,
I Don't know what is about happen, but where do I begin? This is like plastic surgery
EhEHhAehh
Because I'm thinking like what part of his skin can I take
And actually use I'm think I can use his cheeks to make these bit. Oh
my god
It makes me so
UNCoMforTAble
Okay, great. Let's do the chin
My god, I mean I can just steal from the same layer
Reshape it slightly
HehhEhhaHahhah
OHHH GODDD
aahhahaHAHAHAH
That is a butt chin if I've ever seen one
Gawwd
DaAmmnNn
God damnnn boi (lookin fine)
Ah hEheheHE
Doug I'm sorry, I'm doing this out of necessity just
Just understand his nostril is like perfect shape
(wow)
Oh god god god oh god
Oh GOd
What is that
Try to do his nostrils every day we stray further away from God
OHHH GoOOoD
NooO
I think I want to like keep the essence of the smile and not do like pointed teeth for anything
Well so far. All I've accomplished is basically put a bunch of tumor on this poor man's face, but ya know it's pretty good
(indeed it is)
Trying to hold it in my hand
but it falls apart...
(nice singing felix)
*humming* mhmmhmmmm
*more of the song*
(wow amazing job lookin g8)
watch felix start to smile :)
cute
AhhAh AHhhhh
I wanna cry it makes me so uncomfortable
Oh my goddd
EHhhH
BoWsErrR
BoWsERr why aah
*phsyco laugh* AHaheHehaeah
Oh My gawwd
HEheHE
The more I look the more I like -oh god what have I done it ten out of ten
Say it with me ten out of ten
This is what I'm talking about
Huh?
(yes?)
MwAH
Picasso. Picassor would have loved this. Let's look at the original just so we get a sense of contrast Oh God
HAHhahaha
AhEHHwahwah
Kawaii desu
(Took me a long time to do the subtitles and i gave up at the end sorry, but it was fun. till next time)
No more
Well, ask and you shall receive thank you guys for watching another Photoshop video if you enjoyed and want more smash like
speaking of fantastic artworks
Check out the latest merch the hottest merch if you're an absolute madman, only of course
limited time only!! (sub to pewds help increase the sub gap!11!!!!111one:)